[Music]
obsolete object so this is something
that you've lived with for a while
but then
and maybe even got value from it
but it ceased to be valuable at some
point it becomes obsolete in your own
life and usually we'll talk about an
item like maybe it's a dishwasher or
cologne or something like that we have
something
in honor of pete that's a bit more
esoteric right now we have the shopping
mall
now anne marie has a statement about
this a comment alabama would you like to
read her statement please
observation many of the malls in my area
are going out of business or greatly
reducing the number of establishments
storage companies are now moving in and
setting up shop in the places we used to
buy all that stuff it's like all the
stuff we bought is returning to its
original home deep thoughts
it reminds me of alan watts when he
talks about
being born is
waking up after never having gone to
sleep
and for whatever reason i'm reminded
that but and then death is sort of the
opposite of that it's going to sleep but
without ever having to wake up again
and
there's a cycle right
and the same thing is true with our
stuff
i find it really fascinating the picture
you'll see on the screen right here is
which you can see right there this is a
real mall that ryan and i used to work
in this is the town mall in middletown
ohio my whole family is from middletown
ohio aptly named because it's in the
middle of cincinnati and dayton
middletown
and
they uh this mall this is picture i
believe is from 2019
and you could see in this picture
actually there's one store that's lit up
of course it's like bath and body works
because they didn't get the memo that
malls were dying and and so
this mall is one of the creepiest places
i've been recently i went there again
this year remember we were on tour tk we
were in columbus together well i was
staying in dayton and i drove down to
middletown
and i saw this mall was open still which
i was shocked by and i walk into the
mall
and when i walk into this mall
[Music]
it's winter time the heat is not on so i
could see my breath
the doors were open it let me write in
the muzak is playing overhead
creepily
there's gumball machines still filled
with gumballs that no one eats
there's like these different
sort of the ponies you can ride for a
quarter
there is
nothing but abandoned stores all
throughout
and at first i look around i'm like oh
there's that store is closed that wait a
minute
there's no stores wait a minute there
are no customers in here i'm the only
person in this mall
and i'm walking around
and realizing that we have we've reached
this transition point we've in many ways
transitioned out of the shopping mall
experience that doesn't mean that we're
consuming any less it means the way that
we consume has changed we're now buying
things online in droves in fact we've
removed all the friction and so we're
probably consuming more on average as a
result because before you used to have
to get into your car and drive to the
mall and put your winter coat on walk
through the mall and and wait in line
and oh i have to put it on layaway
because i can't afford it or whatever it
was we had all this friction that
prevented
over abundant consumption
excessive consumption consumerism it
didn't completely prevent it but it
added some friction so that we didn't
slide everywhere now when i look at the
town mall in middletown ohio
i see
a carcass of consumerism but consumerism
has been reborn now through online
shopping through instagram ads and so
these places quite often amazon is
actually buying a lot of these shopping
malls
and they're turning them into
fulfillment warehouses
from which they
send you why now why is amazon buying
them because they're close to highways
almost always close to highways which
makes them a great distribution hub
they're abandoned so they can get you
can get a great
uh deal on
buying the building and you just fill up
with stuff and instead of having go to
go to the mall now
so yes the mall is obsolete but it
doesn't mean that it has stopped
consumerism at all
absolutely and
and the shupe and hari and idea of this
is like this drive is eternal this drive
is always at work but how it manifests
itself how it represents itself so will
and representation so how it represents
itself is changing so for example
will we eventually learn that shopping
malls are a bit depressing we eventually
the the luster of that kind of begins to
fade but then
new forms of consumption arise so we're
also consuming differently like people
now i want to consume things that are
that are designer that are small brand
like so your coffee that comes from a
small
coffee maker that maybe you watch on
youtube or whatever it is um
you have to what happens is continually
we kind of learn that something doesn't
work so we find something else that we
think that works
and so now as well we're also buying
lifestyles which is quite different we
never bought lifestyles before so
there's consumerism has to find new
avenues new ways of selling because the
old ways eventually we go that didn't
work but the problem is
we don't it's like people converting
from one religion to another not
converting out of conversion itself it's
like you're kind of going you might move
from
one fashion to another but you're still
in fashion you might move from one thing
that will fulfill you oh i think you
know religion will fulfill me now i
think psychedelic enlightenment will
fulfill me no i think polyamory will
fulfill me now i think commodity
satisfaction will fulfill me just
earthsats god
one thing hasn't changed you still think
something's going to fulfill you so i
know loads of people who go from
religion into
sexual liberation psychedelic
enlightenment commodity satisfaction
it's so
it's like almost everybody i knew
they don't find a way to um to escape
the
desire for that
itself
you know one one aspect i'll add to
what the death of shopping malls could
positively indicate
is that there's been a shift in more
people identifying as creators
with the internet
we have a greater ability to distribute
goods and resources without going
through a centralized hub which means
unlike 50 60 years ago you can be a
nobody in society's eyes you can write a
book without anybody's permission you
can put it up online and sell it to
someone who lives in a different state
you once needed someone's permission to
do that right or you at least had to be
good to do that right now you can create
something that's terrible
and just put it out there that's right
and so now our ability to bake bread to
write books to build things and to sell
it to someone the next state over the
next city over is increasing and so i
think what's happening is
creativity is becoming more
decentralized and we're witnessing our
habits of consumption following a
similar pattern did you enjoy this
standalone patreon highlight if so you
can listen to full episodes of the
minimalist private podcast available
exclusively on patreon visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel one hundred
percent advertisement free